hello everybody my name is nyan i'm the
black female engineer i provide content
for new
and aspiring software engineers and
today we are going over
what my portfolio looked like when i was
going through coding bootcamp is also
the projects i used to apply to jobs and
i just want to provide you with just
some insight of
yeah what you can expect a project to be
i definitely did not have the best
projects
of my boot camp that i know that to be
true
but i also like to think i didn't have
the words i also want to say that
i was applying for junior level roles
i was not applying for the you know
senior manager position like like i was
applying for entry level roles
so just keep that in mind but yeah let's
look at them
so this is the first web app me and a
partner created it was called
mints it was a recipe
type app where kind of like in all
recipes
where you had different recipes here
but you could also search based on
the main ingredient you wanted so let's
say you wanted
a lamb dish
then it would provide all of these
search results
for you
and all of that and then if you picked
one let's say lamb ribeye
then it would go to this landing page
where it showed
the list of ingredients that were needed
and
you could add different ingredients
to like your shopping cart and so
let's say i needed the rib eye the honey
and the powder and so i could
add it to my favorites as well and then
go to
my profile
and then now you see favorite recipes
and then my shopping list so
butter rib eye honey powder
there's another recipe in here from a
previous
and i have not been in here i have not
opened this app
in months and so there's another entry
in here
for favorites but yeah then you can go
let's see if we went back to the rib
eyes that's what we had yes
then you can go to full recipe
and then see the full
recipe breakdown the directions and all
of that
and so if we go back to the home
page
then yeah
we'd be brought to a quick sample of
nine different recipes
and so let's say you wanted to pick
something from here
from the actual sample list this only
needs three let's go to full recipe
taking a hot minute to load but this
also used the
i don't know how to pronounce it it was
the edamame
api i will add a link to it below it was
actually
okay so this is taking a hot minute to
load so let's do a different one
but yeah that api was actually very
helpful it had
thousands of recipes that we got to pull
from let's try to go to this whole
recipe
there so yeah that's
that one that is
mints so the next app created was called
piggy a financial literacy slash
helper app so let's
log in here so users could log
in and start tracking their expenses
let's say your rent is fifteen hundred
dollars
let's say you have a food
and you spend five hundred dollars on
that this month
and also went to restaurant
um and spent let's say a hundred on that
and some shopping
shopping for you went crazy you went
buck wild hence the
financial literacy helper here
and let's add just some savings
let's be responsible adult and put 500
in our
savings this month and so
our total expenses were 3 400
and it lists them out all over here and
then
down here you could see the breakdown
in terms of proportions so 44
was pent on rent 14.7
on savings shopping was over 20
food and then the least amount was
restaurants at 2.9
and so then you could go down here and
just see a couple of articles
for yeah financial literacy so
let's see how to build up your credit
because four hundred dollars
shopping man
and so you can go through these articles
and all of that
then getting back here you can just see
everything all over again so a very
simple app
focused on more just financial tracking
and learning
and calling it a day from there
then we log out and boom
then lastly was the app i can't breathe
it was a progressive web app which means
that
it was compatible with multiple devices
and also you could directly download it
onto your mobile device and use it
without internet connection and all of
that those who know me
know i am very passionate about activism
and making strides for more equitable
and just
world and country and so i created this
app
because of that and overall the landing
page is
multiple individuals who have been
the victim of police brutality or racist
driven
attacks which has resulted in
their death and so if we go to
one individual john crawford iii
we can see how old he was
and the location in which these events
transpired
along with what happened a more
detailed synopsis of what happened along
with the aftermath
in regards to any
repercussions that the police officer or
officers faced
if they went to jail if they were even
indicted etc
you could select to donate
if i click that it will go to
his gofundme page and his family's
gofundme page
if you click sign a petition
[Music]
then it would go to
the relevant petitions
and you could also through this app
choose to look at some resources
aimed at hopefully educating yourself
and
just backtracking some biases you might
have
so books if you select
sister outsider it'll take you to amazon
where you can directly buy
the book you can also
go to movies tv shows etc
and so if beale street could talk
and you can see that you can watch on
hulu
and all of that originally when i
created this app
during my bootcamp it also had
a page where you could take a quiz
and it would kind of reveal your
unconscious bias score and so it would
have a different questions regarding
just how you would react in x y and z
situations what do you think about x y
and z
and it would provide a score for you and
just provide you a starting point for
where to start that journey
and it has an in the news feature where
you can see what's happening
right now currently regarding police
brutality and
the subject matter here and
just read up on those things however
those two features
i had to kind of put them back under
construction
after my bootcamp because i realized
there were things i wanted to change
about them
and so that's why i'm not showing you
them here but that
is what the app also had
and so there are my apps everybody i
know i
told you i had four and i do have four i
was planning to
show you four the fourth one is
having trouble running i think it's
because i have not i literally have not
opened some of these projects in months
and months and months
and so i think some of my programs need
updating
and something like that and so it's
throwing up a bunch of errors when i try
to run it so i'm so sorry
i can show you it it was a react
app where people could pick
i also like makeup and so people could
pick makeup looks based on daytime
versus nighttime and pick different
products based on that
and then shop the products etc so that
was that app was called
rouge but i'm so sorry i can't just show
you all but
yeah those are my apps youtube says most
of you aren't even subscribed and yet i
think you're enjoying my channel so
please subscribe it really really warms
my heart to see this community grow it
also really helps support me and my
channel
so please hit that subscribe button hit
the like button and i'll see
y'all later